after president Trump's incredible press
conference on Thursday a war broke out
between people on the left and in the
media and people on the right people on
the left and in the media insisted Trump
had savaged the media unjustifiably and
lied repeatedly and refused to answer
easy questions and twisted innocent
questions into attacks on the
questioners Jake Tapper of CNN said it
was unhinged it was wild it was an
airing of grievances it was Festivus
those on the right torold gleefully as
Trump savaged the press we were glad to
watch Trump take the air out of the
media's overhyped Flynn hot-air balloon
we were excited to watch Trump redirect
from the media's controversy of the day
approach back toward his policy
victories most of all we were ecstatic
to watch from baffle the media with his
concoction of vicious deserved attacks
on the left
Rush Limbaugh said you get caught up in
the moment but this was one of the most
effective press conferences I've ever
seen naturally those on the Left accused
those on the right of being in a bubble
how could they watch that nutty press
conference and come away happy and those
on the right responded this is why Trump
won here's the truth both sides are now
in a bubble right now Trump enjoys an 84
percent approval rating from Republicans
and those who lean Republican according
to Pew Research he gets just 8% approval
from Democrats and those who lean that
way by contrast at this point in their
presidencies Ronald Reagan had a 39
percent approval rating among Democrats
George HW had a 46 percent approval
rating among Democrats Obama had a 37
percent approval rating from Republicans
this is the most polarized electorate in
modern American history
Quinnipiac actually makes the
polarization even more stark according
to their polling Trump has a 91%
favorable rating among Republicans but a
3% favorable rating among Democrats and
we are less than a month in that's
because everybody is now seeing the news
through the prism of revenge the sec has
a trump this has been brewing for years
those on the right have railed correctly
for decades that the overwhelming
leftist bias in media when Trump II
shouts fake news we resonate we've been
saying the same thing for ever normally
this would probably be healthy the media
have it coming each time members of the
media complain about Trump's attacks on
the press Republicans and conservatives
laugh hysterically we've been the
targets of media bias as long as we can
remember there's something innately
satisfying about watching Trump become
the avatar of our rage
meanwhile those on the Left stand a gate
as the right guffaw sit Trump's fibs
don't they understand frump isn't
answering important questions don't they
get the Trump clearly knows little about
policy and half of what he does know
isn't so we're now at an impasse the
right conflates Trump's fibs
his media slams then we excused both and
the left conflates Trump's media slams
with his fibs and dismisses all concerns
about the media everybody is so excited
to see somebody on the other side of the
political aisle get slapped nobody seems
to care much about what's true and
what's false anymore it's revenge
politics at its finest and that desire
for revenge is reinforced by social
media which encourages you to interact
with people who think like you
social media algorithms dictate if you
enjoy a right-wing outlet you'll
probably like other right-wing outlets
the same holds true on the left
thus everybody on the left believes
Donald Trump has troubling ties with
Russia everybody on the right believes
Donald Trump is a pure victim of the
deep state in the press nobody on either
side acknowledges there may be truth to
the claims of the other because nobody's
even reading what the other side has to
say this is actually a problem it's a
problem for two specific reasons first
the social fabric requires we be able to
discuss issues of the day with one
another rationally and that requires
sharing a common set of facts rather
than everybody bringing their own facts
to the party we can argue over the
conclusions to be drawn from that set of
facts we may not agree or we may agree
but if we can't agree on facts
we can't just then we end up just
standing in our respective corners
screaming at each other second if we
never know whom to believe or worse yet
if we believe that those in power when
they agree with us politically I write
no matter whether what they say is right
or wrong or shortfalls we run the risk
of the actual tyranny truth was supposed
to be the check on government sunlight
was supposed to be the best disinfectant
but if truth goes out the window then
government becomes merely a machine for
retaliation elections just become a
vehicle for taking out your eye on your
enemies this isn't a new problem George
Washington experienced the problem of
partisanship early on in the history of
the Republic he talked about its risks
in his farewell address there's pretty
prescient stuff here's what he said
quote let me now take a more
comprehensive view and warn you in the
most solemn manner against the baneful
effects of the spirit of party generally
the alternative the alternate dominion
of one faction over another sharpened by
the spirit of revenge natural to party
dissension which in different ages and
countries has perpetrated the most
horrid enormities is itself a frightful
despotism but this leads at length to a
more formal formal and permanent
despotism the disorders and miseries
which result gradually incline the minds
of men to seek security and repose in
the absolute power of an individual and
sooner or later the chief of some
prevailing faction more
Abell and more fortunate than his
competitors turns this disposition to
the purposes of his own elevation on the
ruins of public Liberty it serves always
to distract the public councils and
feeble the public administration it
agitates the community with ill-founded
jealousies and false alarms Kindles the
animosity of one part against another
foment occasional riot an insurrection
it opens the door to foreign influence
and corruption which finds a facilitated
access to the government itself through
the channels of party passions
thus the policy and the will of one
country are subjected to the policy and
will of another Washington recommended
we all take a step back and fight
against the spirit of party he said
quoting government's purely elective it
is a spirit not to be encouraged to fire
not to be quenched afire it demands a
uniform vigilance to prevent its
bursting into flame lest instead of
warming it should consume so here's a
mild proposal everybody should call
balls and strikes the media should be
hit when they propagate fake news and
their buyers should be exposed routinely
the left and media should acknowledge
the problem of media bias isn't illusory
Trump should be hit when he lies to the
right should acknowledge the truth isn't
secondary to political power
this may not please those whose first
priority is the victory of their party
on either side but it should make for a
better country a place where facts and
truth still actually matter one final
mode for people on both sides who think
that truth will never defeat lies if you
you know if you unilaterally discerned
by calling balls and strikes you're
helping the enemy if we truly believe
truth no longer holds sway we might as
well end this great experiment of
republican government the argument
against truth is an argument against
consent against representation against
democracy itself i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
all right lots of get to president Trump
has been very very busy since we last
spoke we spoke last on Thursday morning
before that massive press conference we
still have to go through that because
that's still making waves we'll talk a
little bit about some of the policy
proposals that are being tried out but
first we have to say thank you to our
advertisers over at texture comm okay so
if you're somebody who loves reading if
you're addicted to information the way I
am if you love magazines the way that I
do the best way for you to get access to
those magazines is with texture comm so
the way that texture works is for one
price you get access to 200 plus
magazines full of in-depth and
interviews and stories all in the
texture app right on your tablet or
phone it's searchable so you can mark
what you like you can check out back
issues view bonus video contents they
curate articles in magazine it's just
for you or whoever you're gonna give
texture to as a gift this year terrific
service yeah I've been using it myself
and that's why we're gonna have a guest
on in the near future who's I read about
in Reader's Digest my wife's favorite
magazine from texture calm texture is
their fantastic
right now they offer my listeners a
14-day free trial so you can try it out
you go to texture comm slash Ben that's
14 days to try it for free it's $9.99 a
month after that you get over 200
magazines and we're talking major
magazines we're not just filling up the
list of the bunch of magazines they've
never heard of it's not like the local
dental magazine we're talking about you
know People magazine and Sports
Illustrated and Forbes and Vanity Fair
and Rolling Stone and cosmopolitan all
of the major magazines and whether or
not you like magazines it's important
that you be up on I mean this is what I
was just discussing a minute ago very
important that you be up on all sides of
the news so that you can know what the
other side is saying and you can know
the facts they're bringing to the table
that's what texture is for texture calm
you go there right now you use promo
code Ben so that they know that we sent
you get access to those 200 magazines
plus all the back issues it really is a
phenomenal phenomenal app and again you
can use it on your on your phone or on
your tablet as well okay so lots happen
over the weekend and I want to start
with Donald Trump's press conference so
there's a lot here that was good there
was a lot here those bad so it was
interesting I gave a grade to Donald
Trump at the end of last week I do this
every week now and I gave him a grade of
C minus last week because it started off
the Flyn debacle and then he had the
Netanyahu meeting which was great and
then he had this press conference which
was all over the place what I said in
that piece about how to gray
Trump is that one of the problems with
grading Trump is you end up with one
grade Trump is actually a series of
grades right Trump is a or he's F
there's not a lot of in between he's got
really high highs and it got really low
lows and you saw it all in that press
conference on Thursday so the right was
picking out the highs and they were very
excited about those highs and the left
was picking out the lows and they were
very very happy about those lows there
really wasn't much in between and the
question is which side are Americans
going to take or is it all just gonna
become part of the background noise
which is what I actually think I think a
lot of this is gonna become part of the
background noise there's a broader
message I have here for the right that
I'm gonna discuss in just a second but
we'll start off with it with a little
bit of good Trump bad drum because this
was the it was epic good Trump a drum
his ultimate good Trump a drum so he
started off too did President Trump with
some good Trump and that was slapping
the media because the truth is the media
are wildly biased now I would always
prefer that if you're going to attack
the media you do it on the basis of them
lying not on the basis of them doing
things you don't like
you shouldn't attack people just because
you don't they're doing something you
don't like you should do it because
they're lying not telling the truth
saying something that's false I'm
perfectly fine with slapping the media I
do it on a regular basis watch me
anytime I go on any network the chances
that I'm slapping the media are about
117 percent but it's always based on
what did the media do today not just
based on well those darn media people
they're just terrible and Donald Trump
you know finished off this press
conference by the way with a tweet in
which he basically called the the media
the enemy here is that here's the tweet
from Donald Trump and said the fake news
media failing New York Times NBC News
ABC CBS CNN is not my enemy it is the
enemy of the American people that's not
good Trump the part that's good Trump is
the part where he actually slaps the
media for for doing what they're doing
the reason this isn't good Trump is
because the President of the United
States should just as a matter of course
not be calling broad swaths of the
American public the enemy of the
American people it's dangerous language
it suggests that that the I mean unless
he's gonna prosecute them like Barack
Obama actually treated the media who are
adversarial to him as members of the
enemy he actually prosecuted them Trump
hasn't suggested he's doing that yet but
once you start saying things like the
press is the enemy of the American
people you're suggesting that every time
the press attacks Donald Trump they're
attacking the American people and that
isn't
again conflation of something false with
something I don't like is a dangerous
business
and that's particularly dangerous when
you conflate your own interests with
those of the American people when as
president you say an attack on me is an
attack on all Americans that's ugly
stuff okay that's not the way that it
works Woodrow Wilson used to think this
way he used to think that the president
was sort of the Great embodiment of the
American people that's not what the
president is the president is a
constitutionally elected officer with
specific duties if you attack the
president that doesn't mean you're
attacking the American people sometimes
if that were true then we were all
guilty of treason going after Barack
Obama
okay brocco bomb was wrong a lot I don't
like this business where the president
is the representative of all the
American people you attack him you're
attacking Americans - bunch of crap if
you want to say that they're the enemy
of the American people because they're
lying then you have to actually point
out the lies so here was the good Trump
okay there's a little bit of bad form
here's the good Trump Trump starts off
by attacking the median here's what he
has to say unfortunately much of the
media in Washington DC along with New
York Los Angeles in particular speaks
not for the people but for the special
interests and for those profiting off a
very very obviously broken system the
press has become so dishonest that if we
don't talk about it we are doing a
tremendous disservice to the American
people tremendous to service we have to
talk about it but to find out what's
going on because the press honestly is
out of control the level of dishonesty
is out of control
and I think there's a lot of truth to
that I think that the press have been
jumping on every bad headline I proposed
a rule last week that every headline you
don't have to wait 24 hours to find out
whether it's true or not
because there's such a race to be first
and there's also a race to slap Trump to
get Trump that a lot of what's coming
out of the press is false oh this is
good Trump and it's fair for him to say
all of this it's also fair for him to
say that he inherited I'm not wonderful
situation now what I here's what I like
about this it's honest here's what I
don't like about it it's the sort of
stuff that Obama used to say about Bush
all the time oh I'll be okay with it for
a month if in three years Donald Trump
is still saying what a terrible
situation he inherited that's not gonna
wash at a certain point you have to
start being president here's from
talking about the mess he inherited to
be honest I inherited a mess it's a mess
and home and abroad a mess okay so
that's true but again he's gonna have to
stop doing that at a certain point okay
then we get to some of the bad Trump
unfortunately and the bad Trump is just
confusion okay so the bad Trump is
confusion and misinformation and again
this is where I think that it's
important that we note something about
about what people on both sides are
doing and it's not good and that is most
politics and I've said this for
literally years you look back at my
speeches I've been saying this for
probably 10 years most politics is
driven by the negative most politics is
driven by here's what I don't like right
it's driven by as I would say on the
show stuff I hate right most of most
politics is driven by here's something I
don't like so when Trump slaps the media
people on the right share yeah that's
great and it is it's good but at a
certain point you're going to have to
determine whether you stand for more
than just stuff that you stand against
and the danger of falling into the trap
of I'm only going to support politicians
because the politicians are breaking
things I don't like is they may be
breaking things you do like also right
it's possible they're breaking things
you do like also like one of the things
that I like is truth I'm just a big fan
I like facts I like truth I'm not a big
fan of fibs and so when Donald Trump
says stuff like this about the size of
his of his electoral margin this is 11d
you know people on the right sort of
overlook this they said it was no big
deal I don't think it's a huge deal but
I think it is indicative of the fact
that the right bison to Trump because he
slaps the media and they ignore some of
the stuff that he says that isn't true
and I don't see why that should have to
be the case why can't you enjoy him
slapping the media when he's telling the
truth it doesn't seem to me like these
two ideas should be in conflict here's
what he had to say
[Music]
what about Republican yeah yeah well I
was told I was given that information I
don't know I was just given we had a
very very big margin okay yeah I was
just given that information to the
President of the United States for God's
sake you have the greatest information
gathering superpower in the history of
man on your side you can't come up with
like a simple answer for this that
doesn't that doesn't wash people on the
right sort of shrugged it off and
laughed okay fine
it's not a big deal I got it I mean I
don't think it's a big deal either but
when there's a constant stream of this
sort of stuff it's a problem and Donald
Trump makes this happen through a
constant stream here's in a second I'm
gonna play the clip that I thought was
sort of got to the essence of this first
we have say thank you to our advertisers
over at distilled so if you are
interested in jeans you know really nice
jeans but for a price that you can
afford not $200 jeans then you need to
go over to my friends at DST LD comm DST
LD comm and it's what they like to say
it's where minimalistic design meets
maximum comfort basically they're
they're really comfortable jeans they
were they really stand the test of time
they are not complicated they're not you
know rhinestone-studded they're not
trendy they're just great jeans that fit
you really really well and they send
them to you and they're well under $100
they if you get it using using the promo
code you get $10 off your first pair of
DST LD comm / Ben right now you get 10%
off your first pair it's been featured
in all the major magazines I'm wearing a
pair right now DST LD comm / Ben really
some of the best jeans that I've ever
owned I wear jeans like every day so
it's actually important to me what jeans
I wear and the reason that they were
able to save so much is because they're
direct-to-consumer and also because
they're very efficient in their
manufacturing process so you should go
to DST LD calm right now they ship it to
you for free and then if you don't like
the fit then they will take it back
right they'll they take it back from you
for free as well until you find the
perfect pair so there's no risk involved
est LD comm / Ben make sure you use
slash Ben's that they know that we sent
you okay so what I'm saying about Trump
here and I think this is true not just
of Trump
this is true for all Republicans
everywhere a conservative movement in
many cases has become so about opposing
the left which is great I'm opposed to
the left there's no one who fights
harder against the left than I do it's
become so much about opposing the left
that sometimes we're willing to ignore
sins on our own side in order to do that
and I think that that's a mistake
because one of the things that makes you
a right-winger as opposed to a left
winger is the idea that truth is not
relative truth is not malleable truth is
not something that you can just shift
aside for your own political benefit or
for the benefit of the collective and
when you start shifting it aside for the
benefit of the collective you're no
longer on the right anymore so when
Donald Trump says things like this
here's Donald Trump talking about the
leaks this is nonsensical stuff and the
right should not be defending it the
leaks are real you know what they said
you saw it and the leaks are absolutely
real the news is fake because so much of
the news is fake see what well okay so
the question was you said the news is
fake but the but the leaks are real and
he says that's right okay if they're
repeating them if they're just repeating
the leaks and you say the leaks are real
the news can't be fake obviously now I
think what he's saying here what he's
trying to say is that the narrative they
draw from the news is fake that's fine
but he should be more specific in how he
goes about this because otherwise he's
just undermining the notion of truth
altogether and he says this kind of
stuff throughout the press conference
right there was one point where he was
talking about the travel ban and here's
what he said about the travel ban no one
in their right mind believes this wait
wait I know who you are just wait let me
tell you about the travel ban we had a
very smooth rollout of the travel ban
okay so there are two so this is a
perfect embodiment of what the right
likes about Trump and also what the
right should not like about Trump so he
says wait that just am I know who you
are shut up basically and the right goes
yeah that's awesome the media has been
pissing all over Republican presidents
for years I mean George W Bush just hid
in his cubbyhole and and Republicans for
years have been so afraid of the media
and here's a guy who isn't afraid of the
media and that's great it would be
spectacular okay I would be able to sit
here when all happiness just being super
happy about that if for the fact except
for the fact to be saying things that
aren't true okay so two things can be
true at once it's great to media's
getting slapped the media should be
slapped over truth they should not be
slapped over lies okay they shouldn't be
slapped over over things that are being
said that are just false and this is the
point I'm making about bubbles it's
really important you know then think of
think of news like geometry if you're
trying to determine the truth there's a
right-wing line and there's a left-wing
line and they are not parallel okay they
do cross at a certain point the point at
which they cross is the point of fact
okay this is why it's important for you
actually look at outlets from both sides
because if one side says a fact and the
other side says a fact that's the point
where they're gonna meet they're gonna
totally diverge when it comes to the
narratives they draw from the fact but
the point at which they meet is the
factual point and that's what you need
to know okay then you can make your own
decisions but you need to actually
garner facts not just follow the guy
who's slapping the media because yeah
it's fun to slap the media yeah it's fun
to slap the left that's great but this
is a point I've been making for a long
time okay about provoking the left being
a provocateur about slapping the left if
you're gonna do these things the point
here is to tell the truth and if the
left takes offense that's their problem
the point here is not just to offend the
left if you're do if your definition of
conservatism is it makes the left angry
lots of things make the left angry
including some things that ought to make
the left angry okay and it is not your
job just to make the left angry or to
celebrate when the left gets angry you
have to determine are they angry for a
good reason or a bad reason you have to
determine are they angry because you
spoke facts are they angry because you
lied because pretending that everybody
on the left is just an inhuman monster
and that none of them have any capacity
for reason at all and that they're all
just making things up a hundred percent
of the time that's not a recipe for
politics it's not a recipe for having a
rational conversation so all I'm
advocating here is that we all take a
step back here and that we look in the
mirror and then we say to ourselves okay
what's true and what's false we look in
the mirror and we say okay are we
excited because Trump is opposing the
left are we excited because the left
opposes Trump and there is a difference
there is a difference okay are we
excited because Trump is opposing the
left or are we excited because the left
opposes Trump because people use this as
shorthand okay the left opposes Trump
that must mean he's doing something
right not always not always a lot of the
time that's true a lot of the time that
is true but sometimes it's not and
that's true for everyone in the
right-wing movement hey just because the
left opposes you in the right that
doesn't necessarily mean that the left
is wrong okay the left is sometimes
correct about things they oppose they're
not wrong 100% of the time about
everything they're wrong on principles
but they're not necessarily wrong when
it comes to we oppose this person
because he did acts and so it's
important for you as a conservative to
say
do I support this person because of what
they stand for because they stand for
standing against the left or do I
support this person because they're
eliciting a response from the left the
easiest thing in the world is to elicit
a response from snowflakes the question
is how are you doing it and is it a good
thing are you speaking truth and that's
what's taking off the left or is the
left just ticked off at you and now your
entire side goes oh well if the left
stick tauf to you then you must be you
must be doing something right yet in
real dangerous territory when you start
saying just because somebody takes off
the left that means they're a good
person or an ally it's a mistake it's a
big mistake ok so just to finish up on
this Trump press conference he said a
couple of things that were that were I
think silly about the media there was
one point where he said about the media
that it was the fake reporting that was
making it difficult for him to make a
deal with Russia okay he's the President
of the United States if he wanted to
make a deal with Russia he'd make a deal
with Russia and most of the American
people would probably be happy if he
took nuclear war off the table I did I
have to put this in good Trump just
because it is so typically Trump Ian and
I love this quote so much he was talking
about the chances of a nuclear war with
Russia and and it was wonderful it's
just it's you can't help but admire this
language 11g and tell you one thing
about a briefing that we're allowed to
say because anybody that ever read the
most basic book can say it nuclear
holocaust would be like no other
fact-check true nuclear holocaust would
be like no other
fact-check true okay so we're gonna have
to we're gonna have to break there if
you want to watch the rest we have a lot
more coming up that we're gonna be
discussing stuff I like stuff I hate you
go to daily wire.com and check it out
over there $8 a month we'll buy a
subscription to daily wire calm or
eating an annual subscription at daily
wire calm right now if you do that then
you get a free copy of the arroyo DVD
which is a fictional movie about what's
happening on our southern border really
excellent sort of action western flick
modern action western flick about what's
happening on the southern border go to
daily wire comm and check it out we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you